Transcription: Antoine AUDEBERT
Relecteur: eric vautier
Il y a quelques années,
des praticiens du CHU de Limoges
et des chercheurs de
la faculté de médecine discutaient
et ils voulaient savoir s'il existait
un dispositif capable de les aider
pendant les chirurgies du cancer.
Ce qu'ils ont trouvé ne les a pas
vraiment satisfaits.
Du coup, ils ont lancé
un programme de recherche.
Ces recherches ont impliqué des médecins,
des chercheurs en biologie,
en chimie, des physiciens,
de différents instituts
et de différentes sociétés.
La première fois que j'ai entendu parler
de ce programme de recherche
et de ces travaux,
j'ai d'abord été séduit par l'élégance
de la solution qu'ils proposaient.
Et ensuite j'ai très vite vu
l'impact incroyable que pouvait avoir
cette technologie sur les patients.
Alors j'ai décidé de quitter mon emploi,
de me consacrer 100% à ce projet,
et j'ai été rejoint par deux amis,
Alexis et Virgile.
Aujourd'hui nous essayons
de transformer cette technologie
en un véritable outil.
Alors, comment faire pour voir
ce qui n'est pas visible ?
La plupart de ce qui nous entoure
et qu'on dit être invisible
est simplement trop petit
pour que l'on puisse le percevoir.
C'est le cas par exemple des maladies
que l'on ne voit pas directement.
Ce que l'on voit, ce sont les symptômes
qui nous renseignent sur le fait que
quelque chose ne va pas.
Certaines maladies viennent
d'agents extérieurs
comme les virus ou encore les bactéries.
Pour d'autres maladies, elles
viennent de notre propre corps.
Et c'est le cas du cancer.
Tout au cours de notre vie,
à l'instant même où je vous parle,
nous tous, nous avons nos cellules qui
se régénèrent et se renouvellent,
dans un cycle que l'on pourrait apparenter
à la naissance, la vie, la mort.
Tout ça à l'échelle cellulaire.
Par exemple, le foie renouvelle
l'intégralité de ses cellules en 400 jours.
Ceci n'est pas un alibi pour
vos prochaines soirées -
nous sommes bien d'accord.
Et certaines autres cellules se régénèrent
encore plus rapidement.
C'est le cas pour l'intestin
qui renouvelle
ses cellules entièrement tous les 5 jours.
Et durant toute notre vie,
nous allons perdre environ
l'équivalent de 20 kg de peaux mortes.
Vous repenserez à cela quand
vous verrez de la poussière chez vous.
Malheureusement, dans ce processus,
il peut arriver que
certaines cellules dégénèrent.
Cela peut avoir plusieurs causes :
à la fois notre comportement,
des raisons héréditaires ou des raisons
extérieures, environnementales.
Et ces cellules vont
se mettre à dégénérer.
Par exemple certaines d'entre elles
vont devenir immortelles.
Quand j'ai entendu que des
cellules devenaient immortelles,
je pensais que nous allions
tous vivre longtemps.
En fait, non, ça remet juste à plat
tout le processus.
Et du coup l'organe devient
non-fonctionnel.
Donc, à la base d'une maladie
aussi grave, aussi terrible que le cancer,
Il y a simplement des toutes
petites cellules.
Et une cellule mesure environ
10 micromètres.
Ce qui est à peu près 10 fois plus petit
que le diamètre d'un cheveu.
C'est vraiment petit.
(Applaudissements)
Ces cellules sont toutes petites
on ne les voit pas à l’œil nu,
et elles ont une faculté incroyable
qui est vraiment vicieuse,
c'est qu'elles se rendent invisibles
pour notre système immunitaire
et notre organisme ne peut donc pas
se défendre contre cela.
Il existe différentes méthodes pour
arriver à voir des lésions cancéreuses.
Par exemple, Les marquages tumoraux :
on fait un prélèvement, on le marque,
on arrive à détecter des lésions
de quelques dizaine de milliers
de cellules cancéreuses.
Il y a aussi l'imagerie :
on va injecter un traceur au patient,
utiliser un appareil comme un PET Scan
ou un scintigraphe.
Et on va détecter des lésions
de quelques millimètres.
Mais déjà le cancer,
représente des dizaines de millions,
voire des centaines de millions
de cellules.
Enfin, pour qu'une tumeur
soit visible à l’œil nu
qu'elle fasse à peu près 1 centimètre,
on parle de centaine de millions
de cellules, voire de milliards.
Au cours de la vie du patient, la plupart
de ces cancers vont être traités
par voie chirurgicale.
C'est-à-dire qu'un homme ou une femme
va aller sur cet organe
dont il sait qu'il est malade
et va retirer les cellules tumorales.
Mais à un moment donné, malgré toute
son expertise et expérience,
il va devoir se poser cette question :
est-ce que je continue de curer l'organe ?
Est-ce que je continue de retirer
une petite partie de cet organe ?
Si je continue, je peux retirer un tissu
qui est sain, qui est fonctionnel.
Et je peux donc entamer la qualité de vie
de mon patient.
On comprend assez facilement sur des
lésions au niveau du cerveau par exemple.
Par contre, si j'arrête,
si je laisse comme tel,
je prends le risque qu'il reste
des cellules cancéreuses.
Et là le cancer peut revenir et récidiver.
C'est justement pour voir cette frontière
invisible entre les cellules saines
et celles qui sont cancéreuses
que ce projet a été lancé.
Imaginez une cellule.
Donc là, évidemment, j'ai rétréci.
Sur cette cellule,
il y a plein de toutes petites molécules,
ces petites molécules, toutes différentes
peuvent nous renseigner
sur le fonctionnement et le mécanisme
interne de la cellule.
Il suffit donc de trouver la molécule
qui nous dit que la cellule est cancéreuse
et c'est gagné.
En biologie, il existe les anticorps,
vous en avez déjà entendu parler.
Et les anticorps savent faire
plein de choses, notamment reconnaître
et s'accrocher à ces molécules.
En accrochant sur notre anticorps
un fluorophore -
une sorte de lanterne biologique -
qui émet une lumière lorsqu'on l'éclaire.
On accroche donc ce fluorophore
à notre anticorps ;
au moment où notre anticorps va
accrocher la molécule,
il va nous signaler que celle-ci
est cancéreuse.
C'est déjà un très grand pas.
Mais ils sont allés encore plus loin.
Et il se trouve que l'anticorps, lorsqu'il
accroche sa molécule, il va se déformer.
Il va comme plier ses bras
et ça c'est formidable car il y a un autre
effet physique appelé le FRET -
Förster Resonance Energy Transfer.
Je sens que je vous ai tous perdus.
Ce superbe effet, il est assez simple
à comprendre mais il est incroyable.
On a 2 fluorophores,
de couleurs différentes :
un rouge, un vert.
Chacun brille dans son coin,
mais à un moment donné,
à une distance vraiment très précise,
ils vont s'échanger leur énergie.
L'un va transférer son énergie à l'autre.
Ainsi notre fluorophore vert
va commencer à s'assombrir
et le fluorophore rouge va
devenir beaucoup plus intense.
L'idée qu'il y avait derrière
était de prendre ces deux fluorophores,
de les accrocher à des endroits
bien spécifiques sur notre anticorps
qui fait que lorsque celui-ci va
reconnaître une cellule cancéreuse,
en s'y accrochant,
il va modifier la couleur.
Ainsi au lieu de voir une lumière un peu
verte et rouge,
le chirurgien verra uniquement
une lumière rouge
lui signalant qu'il faut continuer
à faire son acte chirurgical.
Mais pour aller encore plus loin,
on a pris ces petits anticorps
on les a mis au bout d'une petite
fibre optique d'environ 2mm de diamètre
pour aller directement au contact
du tissu du patient
et en injectant un faisceau lumineux,
on arrive à savoir
si les tissus sont, ou non, cancéreux.
S'il faut continuer, ou pas,
à faire l'acte de chirurgie
pour donner les meilleures chances
au patient.
C'est grâce à ce projet que l'on peut
améliorer la qualité de vie du patient,
en rendant détectable ce qui était
invisible.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)